très très rapidement dans une violence
extrême on a dû être extirpé de cette
manifestation ces Black Blocs à l'appel
de quelques-uns plus virulents que les
autres et bien nous ont pris pour cible
à ce moment-là et nous ont désigné comme
responsable de ce qui se passait nous
ont traité de menteurs de d'autres
insultes que je ne pourrai pas citer à
l'antenne alors
vous allez souvent les manifestations
pour ces quasiment tout Oui quasiment
toute ça a été souvent chaud il y a eu
des manifestations plus chaudes que
d'autres exemples le 1er mai qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé
forte présence de Black Blocs d'éléments
radicaux parce que pour savoir un peu de
succès genre il y a eu quoi il y a déjà
eu des insultes oui les insultes c'est
je sais pas si je peux les dire à
l'antenne mais
insultes de fachos collabos
menteur
Pete à Macron enfin voilà ce genre de ce
genre d'insultes qui est au bout d'un
moment nous passe au dessus parce que
c'est constamment la même chose vous
allez vous y allez à la boule au ventre
quand vous allez dans les dans les
manifestations non non parce qu'en fait
nous journalistes en tous les cas chez
cnews ceux qui vont sur le terrain c'est
ceux qui ont envie vous êtes volontaire
pour y aller oui voilà alors je suis pas
une tête brûlée mais c'est vrai que je
recule pas devant une bombe de
désencerclement ou un feu de poubelle au
contraire c'est devenu monnaie courante
pour vous connaissez oui on sait qu'on
va au combat en quelque sorte que vous
avez fait insulter vous allez vous faire
voilà est-ce qu'il y a eu des moments un
petit peu plus chaud avant ce moment là
ce qu'il y a eu des moments où vous avez
eu un petit peu peur hier alors hier
juste avant hier il y a rien c'était
possible il y a déjà eu des moments
effectivement chaud avec bah avec nos
agents de sécurité qui sont là
effectivement pour pour
un agent de sécurité par personne donc
j'en ai un mon caméraman on en a un ah
d'accord donc il y a deux avions de
sécurité avec c'est ça donc c'est
important pour être utilisateurs qui
comprennent bien donc il y a deux agents
sécurité un pour vous un pour votre
caméra à chaque fois que vous allez dans
ce genre d'événement tout à fait et des
fois quand c'est très très chaud on peut
en avoir un troisième qui vient en appui
si jamais on a un binôme qui rentre à la
rédaction parce qu'il s'est passé
quelque chose typiquement hier d'accord
nous quand on est rentré à la rédaction
on a un agent qui a été détaché vers un
autre binôme en soutien parce que on
savait il y avait des risques alors
justement hier vous êtes donc à cette
manifestation qu'est-ce qui se passe
alors nous début de cette manifestation
on y va des midi la manifestation des
maracs à 14h mais nous on y va en amont
pour filmer les les préparations donner
les préparatifs pardon donner la parole
aux manifestants ce que l'on fait tout
le temps
on débute le cortège 14 heures direction
Place d'Italie tout se passe bien et on
se pose même la question avec mon
caméraman Florian paume que je salue
salut aussi que qu'effectivement tout
était très calme et qu'au contraire on
pouvait s'approcher des Black Blocs
beaucoup plus facilement que dans
certaines autres manifestations et j'ai
même discuté avec certains pour avoir
des petites infos etc
donc c'était sans savoir ce qui allait
se passer après évidemment donc
racontez-nous parce que vous avez du
discuter avec certains ce qu'on aime
bien savoir il était spectateurs aussi
des coulisses un peu de comment ça se
passe donc vous avez été les voir vous
leur avez dit quoi typiquement je suis
allé les voir dans une situation bien
portée avec les caméras tout ça alors là
j'y étais tout seul c'est ça j'y suis
allé tout seul ou pas vous êtes présenté
je suis journaliste alors il le voit
parce que j'ai le micro il faut savoir
d'ailleurs j'invite les téléspectateurs
à ouvrir l'oeil lors des prochaines
manifestations vous verrez que les
médias aujourd'hui dans les
manifestations d'une part ne montre plus
beaucoup les journalistes pour pas être
opérés et en plus de ça on a des micros
neutres c'est à dire qu'on met plus la
bonnet c'est ça plus être opéré d'accord
exactement alors donc vous allez vouloir
parler vous leur dites quoi alors j'y
vais pourquoi parce qu'en fait à ce
moment là ça fait une heure que la
manifestation a commencé ils ont
toujours leurs bandes il faut savoir que
les forces de l'ordre très rapidement
très rapidement ils enlèvent les
banderoles des Black Blocs puisque c'est
Grande Borne banderoles leur permettent
de se dissimuler leur permettre de se
protéger et là c'est c'est pas passé ça
les forces de l'ordre ne sont pas
intervenues pour enlever les bandes
relais à un moment donné les Black Blocs
se sont arrêtés bloquer le cortège
syndical donc tout le monde était à
l'arrêt ils ont déployé leurs banderole
et plus personne bougeait il y avait des
photos qui étaient prises donc je suis
allé au contact je leur ai demandé
pourquoi vous quand vous êtes à la règle
qu'est-ce qui se passait en fait c'est
un peu étonnant ils se sont arrêtés pour
se prendre en photo
exhiber leur banderole un petit peu en
signe de trophée voilà c'est en tous les
cas ce qu'ils m'ont dit donc ça c'est la
première prise de contact ils ont fait
ça donc là ça se passait bien ça se
passait très bien et c'est là justement
on se dit mais c'est très étonnant
deuxième fois pareil il se reprennent en
photo grandement de rôle entre temps on
passe devant la rotonde donc là quelques
échauffourés avec les CRS on rappelle la
rotonde qui a un lieu qui était le
restaurant Emmanuel Macron avait fêté
ensuite on passe devant une borne une
banque bien connue donc là aussi j'ai de
projectile en direction de la banque les
forces de l'ordre qui se déplorent
rapidement qui sécurisent la zone et
ensuite troisième fois les Black Blocs
redéploie leur banderole et nous sur
l'antenne de cnews on se pose la
question de pourquoi les forces de
l'ordre n'interviennent pas pour
effectivement enlever cette banderole
qu'il est dissimule et donc donc nous on
prend la décision avec mon caméraman de
s'approcher une troisième fois donc pour
filmer cette cette banderole et à partir
de là quelqu'un s'interpose et c'est de
de nous empêcher de filmer donc nos
agents de sécurité qui étaient à côté de
nous et bien sans presse d'enlever cette
personne pour effectivement nous laisser
faire notre travail et à ce moment-là
vous avez les images juste derrière vous
justement à ce moment-là une quinzaine
d'individus s'approchent de nos agents
de sécurité les prêts à partir donc nous
on se retrouve un petit peu
presque seul en quelque sorte et c'est
Black Blocs d'autres Black Blocs profite
que nous agents de sécurité sont
complètement entourés comment ça prend
des coups à mettre des coups aussi bien
sûr et donc il y avait vraiment quoi il
y a eu ils ont pris des coups les angles
alors on a un agent effectivement qui a
pris un coup de poing alors ça va c'est
pas il a il a il lui il a été obligé de
alors de répondre ils sont obligés de
répondre dans ces cas-là comme dans
d'autres manifestations je pourrais vous
raconter des fois où effectivement on
est prêt à partir et on a des agents de
sécurité qui malheureusement nous disent
si on veut prendre le dessus c'est dès
le début qu'il faut montrer qu'on est
les plus forts et à ce moment là comme
et là on va faire honneur à Géral de
Darmanin qui parle de blackburg il faut
bien reconnaître que
en tous les cas nous c'est ce qu'on
constate encore une fois moi je le
rappelle que l'effet et ce que je vois
sur le terrain beaucoup de Black Blocs
ne sont pas issus de blagues Bourges
exactement
on va rappeler ce que c'est que les
Blacks alors les des blagues Bourges
c'est des personnes comme vous et moi je
suis de famille modeste classe moyenne
qui se vêtissent de de
exactement et qu'après on les utilise et
moi j'ai vu des policiers qui me
disaient après les manifestations les
voix sont tous en petites Stan Smith
avec la petite basket on les voit se
changer d'ailleurs exactement on les
voit changer ils sont en train de fumer
des clubs tranquille et voilà c'est des
mecs tu me dis c'est c'est tu peux pas y
penser un instant qu'ils étaient dans
des manifs il y a une heure encore c'est
vrai ils sont difficilement soupçonnés
alors donc là quoi les agents de
sécurité donc se font prendre la partie
tout à fait et donc là quand il y a une
bag donc là voilà il se passe vraiment
quelque chose de dingue alors en plus de
ça il faut savoir que les forces de
l'ordre ne sont pas présents à ce
moment-là pourquoi parce que leur
stratégie à ce moment-là c'est une
nouvelle doctrine de maintien de l'ordre
c'est ce qu'on appelle je l'ai noté une
la stratégie du suivi du cortège en
discrétion c'est-à-dire qui suivent la
progression du cortège dans les rues
parallèles au parcours qu'empreinte le
cortège pourquoi pour pas être visible
justement des éléments un peu plus
violents et pour pas attiser si vous
voulez la violence donc à ce moment-là
nous on est seul avec nos agents donc
les agents sont avec les Black Blocs en
train d'essayer de se défendre et
d'autres viennent vers nous sautent
littéralement sur la caméra de de
Florian la caméra tombe au sol
donc nous là on est pris de cours une
autre personne arrive essaie de prendre
la caméra pour probablement nous la
voler donc nous on s'agrippe à cette
caméra pour la garder finalement et là à
ce moment-là quelqu'un d'autre arrive
arrache vous savez c'est l'œilleton
c'est une pièce spécifique sur la caméra
donc la caméra est cassée il y a des
fils qui sortent sur la caméra nous
jette des projectiles au dessus de la
tête de Florian on s'est passé à 10 cm
de lui alors lui dans la dans la
pagaille il a pas vu le couvenir mais
voilà donc la caméra cassée et c'était
vraiment ouais c'était très
impressionnant donc là on a pris la
décision de de partir
en retraite assez vite mais ils vous ont
suivi vous suivez bien sûr d'accord
vous voulez vraiment quoi casser la
caméra parce qu'en fait il disait
barrez-vous barrez-vous on va vous avoir
enfin voilà c'est que des choses comme
ça et on a quand même entendu un
manifestant il faut le reconnaître qui a
dit parce que là ce que je raconte il
faut quand même bien préciser que 98%
des gens dans les manifestations en
France à Paris sont des manifestants
pacifiques attention c'est bien de
signaler un focus sur les blagues est-ce
que c'est bien sûr c'est bien de le
signaler voilà mais sinon parce que
c'est une nébuleuse c'est-à-dire qu'ils
sont à l'avant du cortège ils sont
vraiment en dehors du cortège syndical
si en fait quasi rien à voir avec avec
les revendications des manifestants et
donc là il y en a un moment vous en avez
un qui a dit quoi et il se voilà se
manifestant dit mais laissez-les faire
leur travail ils font que leur travail
laissez-les ils hurlait comme ça
et donc nous on prend la décision de
partir on presse le pas et surplus
surtout pas courir parce que si on court
ça allait être une chasse à l'homme donc
on part on part et ils nous suivait et
puis des insultes je vous passe les
détails et donc on s'est réfugié dans
une petite rue perpendiculaire et voilà
et nos agents un agent était avec nous
l'autre nous a rejoint et voilà comment
ça s'est terminé donc c'était pour la
première fois je dois bien le
reconnaître un moment de tension si fort
que j'ai eu ouais j'ai eu assez peur
parce que je me suis dit si là nous
agent sont au sol ou qu'est-ce qu'on
fait on a face à nous une quinzaine
d'individus très harnieux et tous les
autres qui sont derrière la banderole
puisque là c'était plusieurs centaines
de donc là ça aurait pu dégénérer ouais
ça fait oui les forces de l'ordre elles
ont vu ça aussi non parce que ils
étaient vraiment dans les rues
adjacentes et puis vous savez il y a
tellement de monde que s'il y a pas de
de fumigène de ou de jets de bouteille
etc il voit pas véritablement ce qui se
passe et puis tout ça c'est passé de
repartir ou pas
non mais je le ferai peut-être
différemment vraiment ah ouais c'est à
dire je j'analyserai peut-être plus la
situation même si je le fais déjà
beaucoup parce que par principe faut pas
prendre non plus de risques inconsidéré
mais
non non j'y retournerai parce que c'est
nous notre rôle c'est de rendre compte
de ce qui se passe sur le terrain bien
sûr tous les téléspectateurs qui sont
chez eux qui potentiellement voulaient
manifester mais qui n'ont pas pu parce
qu'ils étaient pas à Paris nous notre
rôle c'est de montrer ce qui se passe
donner la parole aux manifestants et
puis quand il y a des dégradations assez
de rencontres de rendre compte des faits
vous avez pris des coups pas du tout
alors mon cameraman lui effectivement il
s'est pris un bon
placage en quelque sorte voilà avec la
caméra qui est tombée si vous en
attaquez c'est principalement j'imagine
parce que vous voulez filmer que vous
avez peur d'être reconnu après par les
forces de l'ordre c'est exactement ça en
fait
souvent on peut être reconnu on peut
être reconnu sur le terrain parce qu'il
faut savoir que ces gens-là regardent
beaucoup les chaînes infos donc ils
peuvent me reconnaître des équipements
et donc ils nous
reconnaissent ces cynews attaquer les
voilà là c'était pas pour le média qu'on
représente mais bien pour la profession
que l'on pratique à ce moment-là dans
cette grande banderole qu'on a décidé de
filmer on était la seule grosse caméra
si je puis me permettre de parler ainsi
bien sûr il y avait beaucoup de ce qu'on
appelle de street journalistes vous
savez ces gens avec des stabilisateurs
des téléphones portables qui
retransmettent en live sur Twitter
Facebook etc et nous on était la seule
grosse caméra et donc immédiatement
voilà quelqu'un comme je vous ai raconté
je vais pas refaire l'histoire mais et
c'est effectivement ces black-box ont
une peur bleue d'être filmé reconnu à la
télé mais sauf que nous et j'aimerais
apporter cette petite précision nous en
tant que journaliste qui plus est
travaillant pour une chaîne de télé
nationale on a interdiction de filmer
dans une manifestation des visages en
gros plan d'accord appelle le droit à
l'image donc c'est important
[Musique]
pour vraiment prendre de la distance et
puis avoir une vue d'ensemble et encore
une fois pour respecter l'anonymat des
personnes et là cette personne mais ça
me manque comme ça au dessus de sur la
caméra et il nous agrippe clairement et
c'est là que l'argent de sécurité et le
pouce et puis bon bah là c'est parti
quoi et c'est vous qui c'est la première
fois que les gens de sécurité qui sont
avec vous ce battent comme ça sur cette
manifestation oui ouais on a déjà eu
effectivement un moment donné où on a
parce qu'il faut savoir que les Black
Blocs sont très organisés chacun son
rôle en quelque sorte il y a ceux qui
attaquent il y a ceux qui
réapprovisionnent en arme si je puis
dire par destination pavé bouteille etc
il y a ceux qui s'occupent des cartes et
les journalistes et puis voilà ils ont
chacun leur rôle et effectivement à un
moment donné nous on a été on a été
embêté par par ceux qui étaient chargés
d'éloigner les journalistes et qui sont
venus au contact clairement pour en
découdre eux ils étaient 6 7 ils sont
arrivés en courant vraiment et nos
agents de sécu ont été très très
réactifs et là il y a un coup qui est
parti de notre agent de sécu en
direction
[Musique]
sont reculés et se sont contentés
d'insulter ils sont pas venus au contact
alors qu'ils venaient pour avec des bars
etc d'accord et donc nous à ce moment-là
on est parti et on s'est dit c'est bon
on est on est débarrassé et finalement
non puisqu'il nous suivaient on est donc
on a rejoint le cortège syndical mais ce
petit groupe de 5 6 personnes nous ont
suivi et nous jeté des pétards et ça
nous arrivait dans les jambes enfin bon
il y a des femmes que des hommes alors
il y a des femmes c'est pas la majorité
mais il y en a il y en a mais c'est pas
la majorité qu'est-ce que vous avez
votre caméraman Florian Flo il a dit
quoi il dit
il va continuer ou pas je pense oui oui
ça fait longtemps qu'il fait ça il aime
il aime faire ça et est-ce que vous
alliez vous a dit mettez aussi chaud
au niveau de l'agression ouais ouais au
niveau de l'ambiance générale de la
manifestation non parce qu'encore une
fois le 1er mai c'était c'était le chaos
quoi les immeubles en feu les voitures
c'était quelque chose là au niveau de la
manifestation ça allait même avec les
forces de l'ordre effectivement il y a
eu des échauffourés Place d'Italie à
l'arrivée du cortège mais c'était pas
aussi énorme qu'à l'habitude en revanche
au niveau de cette attaque en
particulier et de l'agression qu'on a
subi de ces de ces Black Blocs là on a
eu chaud et même lui c'est dit que
c'était tendu oui vous êtes très
courageux de venir parce qu'on a échangé
je sais que vous avez vraiment peur
c'est une admissible ce qui s'est passé
moi j'ai une question vous dites que
c'est à la troisième rencontre la
troisième fois que l'attaque se passe et
ce qu'à votre avis ils ont prémédité
c'est-à-dire qu'ils vous ont repéré ils
ont vu qui vous étiez ils ont pris le
temps d'analyser savoir peut-être que
vous aviez que entre guillemets que deux
agents de sécurité ce qui est déjà
beaucoup mais que vous avez que vous
étiez un peu vulnérable
peut-être peut-être je peux pas en avoir
la certitude mais ce que je sais c'est
que comme nous étions la seule chaîne de
télévision avec une grosse caméra à ce
moment là on était la seule cible en
fait et donc il a ça il a fallu d'un
haussement de voix avec ce monsieur qui
a essayé de nous empêcher de filmer et
le garde du corps qui est intervenu pour
qu'en fait ce qui était derrière la
banderole réagissent et viennent
directement au contact je sais pas si ça
a été prédé mais en tout cas il y avait
pas ils avaient pas posé de questions
quoi c'était nous et c'était pas
quelqu'un d'autre il voulait vous
blesser vous physiquement ils en
voulaient beaucoup à la caméra c'était
il voyait que la caméra la caméra elle
est morte là ah bah elle est partie en
réparation et je vais à nos côtés
combien ces conneries
je sais pas
c'était pour vous détendre un peu c'est
vrai que bon on pense aussi aux agents
de sécurité qui ont fait un travail
formidable aujourd'hui c'est plus parce
que c'est fou parce que je pense que
c'est tout nouveau quand même qui est un
agent de sécu par c'est devenu pour un
journaliste et pour un cadreur c'est fou
malheureusement c'est devenu la norme en
fait l'époque des journalistes qui
partent sur le terrain avec des voitures
ciglées sans agent de sécurité c'est
fini nous même on part la plupart du
temps sans voiture pour éviter de se les
faire brûler et puis même sur des
missions on va dire lambda l'autre jour
on était sur un déplacement d'Élisabeth
borne voilà ou potentiellement il
pouvait y avoir des manifestants un peu
plus radicaux que les autres qui
voulaient l'accueillir bon bah agent de
sécurité on n'a pas le choix c'est comme
ça sinon on peut pas faire notre travail
et c'est là où je pense qu'il faut aussi
alerter c'est que le droit d'informer le
droit de la presse est primordial
si les journalistes ne couvrent pas les
manifestations qui va les couvrir est-ce
que ce sont ceux qui couvrent sur
Internet qui la plupart du temps sont
orienter je sais pas qui au fond du mal
c'est exactement ce qui font les
putaclic sur internet
c'est pas des journalistes vous avez sur
le terrain à la confrontation mais ceux
qui font des biens bien sûr qui
reprennent des articles de tel et d'un
tel qui qui écrivent beaucoup de mal ils
remontent beaucoup de mal merci en tout
cas Augustin d'avoir été avec nous
j'envoie Serge on est déjà à remettre
sur le patron de cnews et je vous laisse
saluer évidemment les agents de sécurité
tous nos agents de sécurité qui nous qui
nous sécurisent la rédaction et la
direction de sinus qui a été d'un grand
soutien effectivement